World economic uh Forum adviser the
coming Water Crisis will force people to
accept climate mandates okay let me read
it to you one more time folks the coming
Water Crisis will force people to accept
climate mandates let's see where they're
going with this Mariana mazuk okay an
adviser to the world economic Forum
believes that the impending Water Crisis
will serve as a more relatable and
Urgent issue that climate change stating
water every kid knows how important it
is to have water so there's also
something about really getting citizen
engagement around this and really in
some ways experimenting with the notion
of common good mazuk suggests that the
world economic form may use the water C
may use may
use as it's like a prop may use the
Water Crisis to
advance climate mandates may use to
climate mandate saying World economic
forums globally is may use water a
necessary substance for human life to
create Panic to advance their agenda and
force climate Demand by the way this is
what she this is a quote let me read
this quote again go ahead the world
economic form globalist may use water a
necessary substance for human life to
create Panic key word to scare the crap
out of you to advance their agenda and
force climate mandates the world
economic Forum on its official website
emphasizes the impact of water related
crisis on societies particularly the
poor and cost governor of water AS
Global common good Vinnie and and mind
you and Rob has the video pet so I know
everybody's always like thinks that
we're we're bananas but these people
these evil everybody at these places
that has an accent like clab I don't
trust any of these people and she
actually said and this is what she's
going to say Pat she said we tried to
vaccine vaccinate the entire planet that
failed climate change is too abstract
for people to understand so basically
what she's saying is Pat you know what
we're going to have to do we're going to
mess with the water cuz all you idiots
drink water and this is this is evil
right in your face saying this go ahead
also of course true with coid right we
are all only as healthy as our neighbor
is on our street in our city and our
region and our nation and globally and
did we solve that like did we actually
manage to vaccinate everyone in the
world no so highlighting water as a
Global Commons and what it means to work
together and see it both out of that
kind of Global Commons perspective but
also the self-interest perspective
because it is it does have that parallel
it's not only important but it's also
important because we haven't managed to
solve problems which had similar
attributes and water is something that
people understand you know climate
change is a bit abstract some people
understand it really well some
understand it a bit someone just don't
understand it water every kid knows how
important it is to have water when
you're playing football and you're
thirsty you so there's also something
about really getting citizen engagement
around this and really in some ways
experimenting with this notion of the
common good can we actually deliver this
time in ways that we have failed
miserably other times and hopefully we
won't keep failing on the other things
but anyway you and by the way do you
realize when she said she looks like she
can B two plates 100% like Arnold's
sister she uh the fact that she just
said Pat she goes we tried to vaccinate
everybody on the planet it didn't work
then you know what she says she goes
climate change is too abstract no
you know what that you know what
abstract means we're not believing in
your BS okay the world's going to be
fine but for her to say out loud this is
when I say when evil is in your face and
they're smirking and they're laughing at
you she's saying you know what when we
come after the water then it's going to
be a problem because guess what even
your kids drink this water that's scary
well the thing for me is there's the
problem then there's the solution I
think most people are in agreement on
certain problems okay Co was a problem
all right uh global warming a problem
the Water Crisis it's actually real
especially in subsaharan Africa in the
the Middle East it's Sahara Desert it's
a problem the question is the solution
the solution as we all know during coid
wasn't everyone has to get mandates
everyone has to get jabbed lock it down
probably not the best solution right we
had this conversation the other day with
our friend Liz like what's the solution
to global warming how much of is it
man-made when it comes to water you're
saying that they're using this o they're
being opportunistic to maybe push the
climate change agenda I mean here's the
facts according to Unicef on the global
Water Crisis 770 million people lack
access to clean water that's one in 10
people almost people spend an estimated
200 million hours every day carrying
water the average person walks rural
Africa 6 kilometers which is about 3.7
miles every day to hold 40 pounds of
water and um Urban water demand is
expected to increase 80% by 20 2050
quote unquote UNICEF there's definitely
a global Water Crisis I don't think
anyone's objecting to the fact that
people need water there's a Water Crisis
especially in certain parts of the world
Africa the Sahara the Middle East
Lebanon Afghanistan like everyone in
there like but is the solution exactly
what the world economic Forum suggests I
would be very cautious whatever you know
you know the movie Big Short when the
movie ends and everybody's blown away by
this guy Michael bur you know what the
movie said at the end what Michael bur's
Focus was next after the next Wars will
be fought he said over water over water
oh wow and you know when he said that in
08 dude that guy's a he's a freaking
psychic that guy's good so meaning like
for everybody that's watching this stop
listening to the podcast go to the near
Vons go to the nearest Ralph's or
Albertson's or what what it is it
Kroger's or what is here or yeah Sam's
Club go quietly without saying anything
to the owner go quietly fill up every
single cart that you have with every
water they're selling and just spy it
and get one of those
commercial get one of those any reason
why you just a party just a
part no reason I'll add one more thing I
mean we're so lucky here in America that
this is not our daily lifely issue and
when it is like Flint Michigan a few
years ago oh bro everyone took notice oh
Ancient Ancient pipes and lead poisoning
in the city what there's no clean water
in what is America what is happening
right now still a problem we just talked
about in um East Palestine right the
water that was basically turned toxic
after they still thank God in America
these are oneoff segmented issues
imagine being in other parts of the
world and literally not having access to
clean water so think twice before you
talk about America go move anywhere
else in the world let me know how the
water situation good luck so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here